News is reporting it as well times 12
times on their Instagram story right
with articles that literally say nothing
whereas typically they just say silent
when they don't have the information
it's as if they want this to be put
forward I have to believe that it's true
and I'm just so goddamn Chuck and we're
gonna I mean maybe we should just start
with that like just get right into the
Fast Five because honestly there are so
much news that we can't even talk about
Teresa Giudice is a new boyfriend you
know really no time for all of the news
it's like a a plus plus plus list ya
know it's almost like the universe knew
we were getting married and they had all
the good stuff until the day after we
were done recapping the wedding then
they're like okay universe gaga go
Jordan go Tristan go Teresa go Carl die
you know yeah thanks Kim fashion OVA oh
my god there's just so much to unpack I
mean okay do we have anything we want to
recap before we jump but usually we
shoot the [ __ ] we'll just tell you like
okay so we have the fast six today
because the world just doesn't stop
turning and we're gonna be recapping
Siesta Key Vanderpump pearls and Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills tomorrow is
d-day Nick vile is coming on the toast
tomorrow
Nick vile is coming on the toast
tomorrow Nick on the toast Nick on the
toast Nick on the toast but I'm pom-pom
Nick on the toast it'll be a great day
for us to you know eat our words swallow
our pride and apologize and you know
there are very few things I hate more
than apologizing
no but I'm no you know what sometimes it
can be so therapeutic to get all that
like anger and heat out of your body I
feel lighter well you look nice today
Thanks I mean I thought we had a big
morning here you know so if probably
there's a lot of confusion in the
comments why I'm wearing a stiletto a
point yes stiletto and it's because I'm
Jackie and I had a very important
meeting after the toast that was
scheduled as I was on my way here you
know wearing Spanx no underwear pointing
heels eyeliner and
don't think there's there's anything
that makes you feel like a big there's
nothing that makes you feel more like a
loser loser they're like showing up to
work like overdressed but they'll
usually you can be like notes cuz I have
this like important thing yeah like with
having nothing to go to afterwards no
it's it's very sad I like and now I have
to like they cute again tomorrow and I
say I can't even see my clothes my
apartment is a complete [ __ ] cuz the
registry because of the registry because
we moved out and we move back in and
like I'm just too tired to even to
unpack a thing and so so don't chug you
don't unpack your things
unpack the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast but
before we you know waste the good
surprise I know you we're having audio
issues and I want to make sure they're
cleared up before we get into the deep
news because I don't want to I don't
want to talk about this twice it's too
upsetting yeah so I'm gonna go weird are
we good
oh we're good we're good okay without
further ado first up Khloe Kardashian
reacts to Jordan woods his cheating
rumors after Trent's Tristan Thompson
split Khloe Kardashian interest in
Thompson's love stories officially over
and she's reacting to reports that
Jordan woods is the cause he news can
confirm the famous couple is broken up
ten months after the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star gave birth to their
daughter true
we're told the pair will remain focused
on co-parenting their little girl as
Khloe continues to live in Los Angeles
California and Tristan travels across
the country due to his basketball career
Hollywood unlocked reports that the pair
officially called it quits after Chloe
learned about an alleged affair between
Tristan and Jordan who was Kylie
Jenner's best friend and houseguest over
the Valentine's Day weekend Tristan and
the 21 year old met up at a private
party at out at his la home where the
partygoers claimed to have seen the two
a listers looking suspiciously intimate
but it's like if he was throwing a party
why wouldn't Chloe be there no there's
so many things that are weird what the
hell is Hollywood unlocked that's the
first question and since when did they
become CNN however the Cleveland
Cavaliers player does not denied the
claims and said that their fake news in
a since deleted tweet it seems Chloe
disagrees with his assertions though
since she and her friends commented on
Hollywood unlocks Instagram post about
the affair Chloe commented
of shouting emojis while besting Malika
Hawk wrote strong facts Larsa Pippen
chimed in with an Amen well what's so
interesting is that Khloe's comment in
particular isn't necessarily a
confirmation because there has been
little to no statements put out by the
Kardashian camp themselves just Khloe's
I don't count Malika and Larsa as a
Kardashian just Khloe's comment and
Khloe's comment was the emoji of ass man
silhouette shouting which could be like
oh all you people always talking [ __ ]
you know like it could mean something
else even though it's totally true no
and by the way I am taking Malika and
Larsa like they krashen's rain in their
friends yeah therefore Jordan woods
apparently yeah and so if they're giving
weight to this gravitas I really I think
that it's true what's so crazy when it
first came out of the TMZ headline was
Chloe and Tristan split after a rumor
that he slept with Kylie's friend and I
was like well we only know of one of
Kylie's friends and there's no way it
could be Jordan she must have another
friend but the fact that it's Jordan is
[ __ ] know I mean I put on a shot of
TMZ sports in our chat and I was like
there's no way this is true but it's
like usually TMZ TMZ is not the most
unreliable like as much as they have a
reputation for being like trash tabloid
like they do their research and they get
the paperwork and they're in kris
Jenner's pocket right and I go back and
forth because on the one hand like Oh
TMZ says it's true because they like
face their stuff in like fact base like
courthouses but on the other hand they
spread they they literally when they
were talking about you said the most
untrue oh that's so true the today at
8.2 million followers when I had to
point and you know what I wasn't mad but
they also said President Trump tweeted
about me which like honestly I would
have loved the press but he did it right
so like they actually are get it wrong a
lot so we only know what I'm demanding a
recall right there was a fake trem feed
about like this was like years ago
before Trump was even political when he
was the guy who a Celebrity Apprentice
and each media hilarious things like
I've never seen a thin person drinking
diet coke so true so I made a fake tweet
that said man that girl's no job is one
funny gal and I posted on my answer I'm
being like oh even
Celebrity Apprentice loves me this was
literally 2012 like they put it on TMZ
TV show they have a TV show
they wouldn't even TV show about saying
that I had a punchy million followers
and that President Trump
they're like oh she's trash Trump
tweeted about her Mike first of all it
was baked meat check it was before
people thought Trump was trash all right
third of all she has two point eight
million followers all right you don't
need to harp on that okay like they
don't need to review that now she has
three million that's true anyways and
here's my thing I cannot deal and I
can't stand when people are like it's
publicity or the show like nothing they
have ever done whose turn out to be
publicity for the show this time last
year it broke that tristin was stepping
out on Chloe nothing that has ever
happened has got turned out to be
publicity for the show the ton no no
this is a guy Lee being pregnant it's
all real it's just the timing is
definitely when does the show King soon
when literally in a week I think
actually no this week but I just think
every week news comes out guys like
Kardashian said that's interesting
you're not and I like this and not like
the Chloe Tristan stuff last time I
definitely think that what happens is
true but the way and schedule and the
show is over a month away in the
schedule in which they release stuff is
definitely in their favor and that's
fine if Chloe's baby daddies gonna cheat
on her she should at least get the upper
hand and in saying when it gets released
I'm sorry the show premieres March 31st
you guys are well and this is called
fake [ __ ] news it probably everyone's
saying it's premiering this week they
started Eve I bet a tweet that over my
butt actually reported that said it was
the eve of keeping open aggression and
then I was like oh wow Kardashians
premiered on psychiatry to the other
yeah you guys the world is [ __ ] crazy
March 31st apples oranges a [ __ ] has
one has nothing to do with the other and
every time someone has accused the
Kardashians of doing something for press
it has never turned out to be that way
it always has turned out to be just what
really happened yeah so like I'm yes the
devil works hard but Kris Jenner works
harder and Smith Jenner works even
harder but like this is just their lives
their lives are just this interesting I
do think there's a certain limiting to
look at I think there's a small amount
of manipulation that goes on just in the
way that information gets released the
way that they all react to it because
they are this like camp and they want to
be in control of their image and that's
fine but what happens is real yes I
completely agree but wouldn't you like
if something crazy you want to be at the
front of
you want to have all your ducks and
orders yeah when they press go you know
Security's on their way in before Jordan
can pack up her things right she has
some extra Kylie lip kits you know that
name was the means have been [ __ ]
spectacular honestly for a while there's
been a drought in meme culture like
nothing really happened that shook the
world quite like this has and I mean I
posted to a plus means feel free to
check about a girl with no job but just
the toasters group has been lit up like
there's just so much good content coming
out of this and for that I'm truly
grateful for - Jordan woods but I just
want to talk about let's take a step
back let's think about Jordan woods his
mindset because the here's what we know
about your under once she grew up with
Kylie um I've been hearing for a while
that she actually comes from like a
well-known Hollywood family that her mom
is like a socialite my Instagram says
otherwise but whatever make sense
because like they they went to school
together you know yeah she's a sister
okay and her and her mom are close she
lives in Kylie's house yeah she has a
car bought by Kylie she I'm assuming his
revenue streams from Kylie directly like
collabs but then also she is an aspiring
model and a personality social media
sensation all off the coattails of one
Kylie Jenner and Kylie um we got to see
a small snippet of Kylie in life of
Kylie and then her brief time on the
show but Kylie is very invested in her
friendships maybe even more so than her
relationships with her sisters like yeah
she invests financially but also
emotionally in her friendships with
Jordan with Stas I'm Harry Arielle
Victoria and that's what we got to see
in life of Kylie so you know the
question must be asked is what do you
think on God's green diddly dally earth
was going through Jordan woods his mind
when she made this enormous enormous
[ __ ] given all of that I can only
think one thing
it's true love and they're gonna get
married it has to because it has to be
that's the only way that this would be
okay I always say like there are girls
like even in our friend groups or like
people that we know like who hate each
other because they stole their boyfriend
or whatever in high school but then like
the girl who stole the boyfriend ended
up getting married and having kids with
the boyfriend it's like can't we let go
once they get married that makes it
right it
interesting like get married you know
it'll one day make it right or like she
wouldn't just bite the hand that feeds
her you know become home ready
chugging Carly what if she's pregnant
homeless Karlis jobless without having
somewhere to go next you know maybe
she's moving to Cleveland Chuckie what
if she's pregnant I wouldn't care you
know immediately
that's us bye baby I know like honestly
I didn't care about Tristan Thompson
before I cared about him who's Chloe
cared about him now that he's out I
don't care about him I never cared about
Jordan woods but I maybe cared about her
because Kylie cared about her Kylie
doesn't care about her I don't care
about her the two of them can go live in
sin somewhere but it's like Jordan is
really in the past like six month like
snatched it up like she got her gap
closed she's been looking so good it's
almost like she was getting ready for
this big media moment I mean even just
last night she went from 8.1 to 8.2
followers on Instagram like this is her
moment I'm gonna say that's not
impressive do you think Kris Jenner
manages Jordan looks like she every time
I go shopping on ASOS Jordans right
there
so is that girl from The Bachelor me
Kris Jenner no but now her she's being
blown up with maybe Kris Jenner it's
like all right you can [ __ ] my
granddaughter's baby daddy but I want to
have % of everything you're gonna get
because of it I don't know it would be
like Kris Jenner managing blac Chyna
what's the point but no there's
literally no money there I mean I knew
it at one point there was she was doing
club whoo here and says while she was
pregnant like there's 10% in that that
was wild you can get 10 4 she was doing
Club appearances while she was pregnant
and they made Rob fly coach do you
remember that yes that was horrifying
that was a really dark time for like yet
Jordan will have a spike right now and
interest but it'll peter out you don't
like know the Kardashians hotels
especially when also I have been hitting
up all of my sources just to get
confirmation especially in the early
hours I was like this can't be true like
it literally felt like April Fool's Day
like a prank so I got one confirmation
yeah and one awaiting confirmation I
haven't gotten any like no this is
[ __ ] yeah I I'm I'm feeling like
it's true even by the way if it weren't
Kylie would Kylie would post something
with Jordan like just like leave my
friend alone you know or even just a
selfie of them to let people know that
like Jordan is she's cool with Torian
and but
I'm going on nursing yesterday in the
Kardashian camp right the only person I
feel bad for in this whole situation is
Kylie I don't feel bad for Khloe because
I'm sorry like this isn't the most
shocking news and for Khloe it's just
that Tristan cheated on her it doesn't
matter who it was with it she doesn't
have an allure Alliance to Jordan I'm
sure they have a friendship but it's
Tristan being a piece of [ __ ] once again
and and it's not surprising for Kylie
it's like she just lost like her best
friend no it's half of her heart in the
words of John Mayer yeah so and also
it's like and if she doesn't turn on
Jordan
then she'll lose her no I mean she has
to because like there's you can say
anything you want about the Kardashians
like they use their bodies there and
whatever but they value one thing two
things money and loyalty like they keep
people in their circle like even though
people say like Jonathan's crazy like
he's never been nothing but loyal to
their family doesn't sell sorest stories
to the press like that is truly what
they value so Jordan has now lost the
one thing she had which was loyalty
Jordan didn't offer Kylie anything
except companionship a safe space loyal
friend and now she's lost that one
element that's what Kylie seeks out
that's what they all seek out when like
you're the most popular world all people
want from you is money is fame is it's a
collab like people want everything from
you and the one thing that you can't buy
is loyalty yeah and that's what Jordan
was like she was a lifelong friend she
was there through everything kept the
pregnancy quiet like she was there
through thick and thin and never wanted
anything from Kylie everything Kylie
gave her was because Kylie wanted to
give her could Jordan right now seems
like Kylie I need a car which is why it
has to be true love oh so they're just
yeah it's so devastated there's fake
news going around that the sisters have
unfollow Jordan they I just checked they
have not kylie-san follows her and Chloe
still follows guys this is so
frustrating because I've been seeing
this all over to it Irving's all the
time like this if you want to check okay
you this is what you do you go to Kylie
Jenner's page you click following and
you search Jordan what you don't do is
go to Jordan's followers select the 8.2
million followers and search Kardashian
because it's not correct you can't
search 8 million people it's not hot
it's too hard but you can search the 200
that kind of silence it drives me nuts
every couple hours it's a huge shock she
and Donald look at such good as she
didn't Judith Fowler
it doesn't work searches the following
did not the followers yeah I saw someone
put that in Muhammad's and I have been
keeping I've been checking every other I
know I would see this comment if you
like oh my god let me show you yeah but
I'll check I made such a good point
every time hold on where is this Casey
asked with Chloe usually speaks out or
makes a joke about these outlandish
stories on Twitter that makes me think
that this is true it's really true she
always quote tweet these wackadoodle
publications and is like you guys need
to like go back to school no and she's
putting up like quote season on her
Instagram stories of like emo quotes
about it's like if you've been in our my
friend for at least seven years you're
considered family she's like putting out
she's like searching quotes like when
your man cheats on you with your
sister's best friend right post
yes should we make any more obvious that
we are in fact onto something I just my
world I kinda dream about it like I'm so
invested in and emotionally that like my
subconscious is thinking about it like
even when I'm sleeping it's truly
shocking and I just hope it was worth it
Orden I can't imagine that it was but I
sure does look what you've done you've
made a fool yeah and you know what I
hope you guys live happily ever after
because it's the only way that your love
but at the end of the day like let's
just think for a second like it was just
like they were wasted like it was a
drunk
huge mistake like there's nothing there
look at all that you lost because you
couldn't control yourself when you were
drunk I mean if someone was later by one
Kylie's best friend I would never get
drunk of course it's too much of a risk
I mean as a drunk person believe you or
like the kind of drugs that hooks up
with people's right men well I'm not
that kind of drunk I'm just like the
kind of drunk who it says and does like
evil horrible things and that's bad too
so like when you so much to lose like I
mean I guess I actually do have a lot to
lose like I have a wonderful family a
wonderful husband a son I should stop
saying evil things when I'm drunk but
like if you have like that much to lose
especially like from a financial
standpoint like you cannot afford to be
going out without Kyle I know and it's
like when you're best friends with Kyle
you when you're invited so completely
into Kylie's life I would say more so
than Kylie's mom why would you even
leave her side
she needs you right and do like smiley
she got drunk and they hooked up mate
dancefloor make out maybe but like why
did she go to the party in the first
place you know without Kylie right and
with how Chloe being there apparently
that was almost like when Steph Shep was
going out with Courtney without Kim when
she was still working kind of you know I
mean it's not even close to like the
level but it's the same I think that
part of the reason why Kim wasn't happy
with Stephanie was like she was getting
too into late the socialite the going
out words like you're you have a job
like go to work right but that's the
Jordan doesn't have a job and she is
supposed to be a socialite I'm just just
not a homewrecker anything but a
homewrecker and there she went back to
home and you know what like I honestly
at this point I hope that it's true
because we've been slandering a woman
before noon left and I I would very much
like to check Chloe's Twitter just to
make sure she hasn't said anything
because she really is always very
transparent like they don't wait to do a
whole GMA special you know
no she doesn't write it in let's see
what Chloe liked on Twitter oh okay
ki 16 don't let anyone ever say this is
your fault he is a sick man and if it's
true then she has a terrible woman both
terrible people that do not deserve your
love true does and you're doing great
showing her that love so someone tweeted
that at khloe and khloe liked it Wow
oh and more than just Kylie giving her
home in a life and a family in the car
Chloe employed her as a good American
model right because there's they're so
size inclusive fired no it's just like
paycheck after paycheck when are they
gonna take down the Kylie X Jordan
collab off of Kylie no it ate some it's
on it's on sale right now use code
betrayal for free shipping buy one get
ten off though that was Nora's black
book
nori spot book is the rate of scout
Gianna Kayne when he was on Instagram
for a while screenshot of it was like I
love this account that is so funny it's
it's an account that like it's at anyway
seven pretends to be Northwest and it's
like so [ __ ] it's so funny and they've
all interacted with it
for like moments that is so funny that
won t it's and actually she should meet
hit the thing honestly I think I know
why they had not I think I know why they
released all this yesterday because they
wanted to deflect from the travesty that
was Kourtney Kardashian's Instagram
giveaway
go to her Instagram do you know many
people posted in the toasters only that
Courtney's Instagram got high honestly I
couldn't stop watching my own story
yesterday's okay I understand go to her
Instagram she's lying on a bed of like
Louis Vuitton bags you say yes look at
the caption it's six miles long does
that look like something that happens
when you're giving away his clothes oh
they did they remove the caption Jackie
it was oh my god like six pages long
everyone thought she everyone thought
she was happy it was so embarrassing and
honestly now I know why they had to
unveil this whole thing yesterday we and
also because the Kim Kardashian fashion
Nova of it all weight quickly I just
want to say one thing before we move on
to the Kim Kardashian fashion I was
gonna move it to our tan but we'll do it
right now is something interesting that
enews posted and enews when only when it
comes to kardashian you take everything
they say as to me straight from the
horse's mouth because they have are in
the ears of the Kardashian or they or
they just don't say anything and so if
they say something it must be true
because they wouldn't post falsities
about their you know their breadwinners
so they said Kylie has been you know
devastated heartbroken for days or Khloe
has been yes and as of yesterday Khloe
and Kylie were liking and commenting on
on her instagrams
so that timeline doesn't make sense why
are you laughing Courtney's things no it
was like the caption was like a CVS yes
it was so trashy people thought and it's
like remember when she responded to
someone I was sorry I did get on the
phone with my lawyer seven business
feels like was this one of them because
you made a new [ __ ] lawyer horrifying
the terms and conditions I think even
under eyes you couldn't have the fun
with her lawyer she's still writing that
caption oh my god horrified like she is
what did she have a hundred million
she had a hundred yeah god no no like
fifty really yeah only Kourtney and I
only Kim and she's at 73
what's Chloe at like 90 let's see
seventy five million followers and you
couldn't get a better like sponsored
post oh he's at 86 Kendall is at 127 Wow
Kendall is at 104 kylie is at 127 also
Wow yeah
so I feel like this whole thing is
definitely gonna make her surpass Kim in
terms of followers I mean not if she's
radio silent
Jaggi
it was horrified I think I and that was
like first I'm like oh that's a cute
picture like she's laying on Louie
Vuitton like haha then it's with a
caption oh my god she got hacked I
wonder if she knows like someone tell
her lawyer so a lawyer to get on the
phone hang up on the other seven deals
oh my god I can't believe I didn't see
that as I get from not following her no
totally Jackie was so funny okay are you
ready for Kim Kardashian yes Kim
Kardashian denies any part in designer
fashion knockoff scheme mere hours after
Kim Kardashian stepped out at a
Hollywood Beauty Awards at the Hollywood
Beauty Awards in a revealing strappy
gown pulled directly from the tightly
guarded feet Thierry Mugler archives Pat
fast fashion website fashion OVA already
announced they intended to knock it off
for the mass-market crowd some assumed
that the timing wasn't by chance
indeed Popol Fashion Police Instagram
account at Dyea Prada did some sleuthing
of their own and came to the conclusion
that Kardashian herself must have been
involved in the process well Kim what
this article fails to mention and the
only reason people are really talking
about it is like nobody really cares
that Kim wore a dress in fashion oh I
knocked it off like that's just the
nature of the fashion industry but Kim
went on the Twitter and Instagram rant
saying like she has worked so hard for
so many years to preserve these
relationships with like top designers
they're like they're not gonna want to
work with her is every time they wear
something it gets knocked off and these
companies make millions of dollars and
the original designer makes no money
which is a good point but she posted
those Instagram stories in response to
this guy at products I thought it was
afterwards no W Magazine says it who
likely she had them type Radha said
fashion of a house model Yoda Yamane
Mayer Knight may not have accidentally
leaked his story two and a half hours
earlier of photo options from her shoot
featuring the Mugler replica he burn up
but I don't know if it's a he or she
daya Prada wrote on Instagram of the
fashion of a knockoff the file names
were even labelled Kim dress while it's
now being called whoa winning beauty cut
out gown lol this begs the question the
fashion of a whip up the dress overnight
in their Los Angeles Atelier after
seeing Kim minute or she peddling her
vintage finds some mass retailers ahead
of debuting them for a calculated timely
release Kardashian who likely saw this
post has now hit back at the insinuation
that she's borrowing from designers only
the profit from ripoffs of their
creations the reality TV star took to
Instagram stories were
she revealed that she played no role in
the knockoff of her Mugler dress while
defending the Fashion Designers she
collaborates with it's devastating to
see these fashion companies ripoff
designs that have taken the blood sweat
and tears of true designers who have put
all their all into their own original
ideas I've watched these companies
profit off my husband's work for years
now and that it's also affecting
designers who have been so generous to
me to give me access to their beautiful
works I can no longer sit silent I just
really want to check with what came
first hey guys she tweeted because she
tweeted and then she put them on her
Instagram stories like a couple hours
later just like the same thing but 22
hours ago she tweeted they posted this
thing Oh two days ago oh you're right
you're right you're right okay so
they're the diet Prada siya Danis went
on so what she also and not only that it
had the date to February 15th yeah what
she posted was in response to the
insinuation from Diet Prada that she's
working with fashion OVA and these fast
fashion brands to sell pre sell her the
things that she's gonna wear they get it
on the site and then she wears it and
they're ready to go and they're working
together right but she famously turned
down over a million dollars from Fresh
Innova because they steal from so it's
like it's almost like if she was doing
this like she should have remained
silent on all fronts like not ever come
for fashion over not ever since she
turned down a million dollars because
then she has made herself like a target
when it came to fashion oh man no one
would even be thinking about her I
didn't even realize that they like I'm
like I don't know I just I guess they
like when every one of them wear
something they make a cheap version of
it like I just didn't think I was a big
deal yeah me neither
I actually like maybe I just in blind
love for Kim but I vote I don't think
that she does this like I don't think
she needs that that sort of money if
anything she really wanted to do this
she would wear the club she would start
her own fashion line and create rap
because of everything that she wears and
then cut in the design like something
else but I do think someone in her camp
is leaking them that's possible that's
what I really think cuz I don't think
she's that thirsty or like or desperate
for money like you know I'm like if this
came out it's like 100 percent sure like
that's mortifying like it's not worth
the money to be late look she really has
for so many years like she went from
being a Joe who like nobody would dress
to literally like making custom and
Siobhan Shay wedding dresses and getting
custom Stella McCartney for all of her
kids like she really has worked so hard
to preserve these relationships with
like major fashion houses that I don't
she would be so stupid I really don't I
would be shocked if this is true I would
be more shocked if this is true than in
Jordan would st. Tristan Thompson slept
together is true but at the same time it
definitely is annoying for her to like
wear a gown and then random companies
make like just overnight like a couple
million dollars off of something she
wore and it's only popular because she
wore it you don't even yeah that's
annoying
why because she would want to get in on
it he of course she's making all these
people money and getting none of it in
this particular scenario yeah I don't
know yeah I could understand I wanted to
get in on it but it's just something
that she would I just don't think it's
worth I don't really wanted to be making
money off of her own looks she would
find a way to do it in a more elegant
way yeah like she has enough capital to
start a clothing company but you know
the kids supply I don't think it was a
big hit so maybe she was turned off to
the apparel industry right and it's like
she's not gonna start a clothing company
of knockoffs of designer dresses yeah I
don't know be kind of smart if she
worked with fashion know that you know
this would be a great idea you know he
should do she should start like you know
how I Missoni and like random brands do
Target or H&M like what's a called
what's the word in I feel pretty
diffusion diffusion like she should do
random like collabs with huge designers
at a reasonable price not reasonable
like $100 like we does more like 500
yeah but it's like that all of that
takes so much time and I've heard him
work in like fashion over any has it on
their website and in the time that she
thought of the idea totally ration of I
just made it just so crazy because when
fashion of a first started like popping
off it was like so tacky trashy like you
would rather die then we caught dead in
fashion Nova but now they like stores
they are make so much money and I think
I heard a rumor that like Amber Rose
owns a part of it really yeah but I also
could have just made that up that's
interesting
also I saw the toasters are just you
know on mean Patrol for the Kylie
Tristan Jordan thing and someone was
saying how like they all cheat you know
like oh you mean how like Kylie cheated
on by Tyga with vagina
Kim was best talking about China and
Amber Rose and you know Chloe still
Tristan from someone and then stole amar
from his high school sweetheart whatever
and it's like nobody cares that Tristan
cheated on Chloe no offence yeah we
would Kerry would be talking about it
but we wouldn't care it's the fact that
Jordan is Jordan it would even be
different if it was
stas yeah no Stas doesn't live with
Kiley like also the fact that it's
Jordan I'm British so shocking I take
umbrage with the example blac Chyna was
best friends became like best friends
really no they were friendly like they
got a washer together I wanted a picture
guys after badly she had something going
on with Kanye like they were really good
acquaintances like let's not even begin
to equate it with the relationship that
Jordan had with Kylie please right and
it's like Kylie stole blac Chyna's man
technically that's not the same as like
it would have been if Kim's best it
would've been that Larsa stole Kylie's
man right you know it's not the same
like my sir is looking so different I
suggested and Kylie and came I'm not
investing to buy China I don't care that
her man got stolen
no like I care that Chloe's man got
snatched by Jordan Woods now that he got
snatched but by Jordan woods where is
Jordan woods right now like she in a
hotel he's in hiding she she does on a
car anymore she's in a bunker with Kimmy
Schmidt he's got an underground she's a
mole woman she's got an underground the
Reverend took her No you know where she
is she's in Cleveland on a honeymoon
with Tristan Thompson because they have
to be in love that's the only place she
could be you know if I found out that
they're not married with a child on the
way like I will be devastated and
embarrass Sado for everyone involved
yeah people are giving more examples it
would be if Malika [ __ ] Kayne yes yes
Wow great really puts it into
perspective mm-hmm like it's and I just
can't help but think and I know I'd say
that I've already said this but I just
can't help but think how truly
devastating this must be for a million
reasons but most of all because the one
thing the Kardashians value that they
really have a hard time finding is loyal
people that's why I want to put myself
out there as you want an addition I want
to addition obviously to be Kylie's next
best friend but just like include me in
the circle like you won't regret it
first of all like I'm so funny like I'm
I'm a great guest at like parties I have
a good time I drink but like I don't
over drink to the point where like you
have to be like worried about my kid
falling out I'm super loyal like I've a
Lee being your friend and like caring
about you and making you feel better
than I do like my own Instagram
followers before no seriously really
yeah I don't know I think it would be
hard for you know oh my god woman for
the job oh my god Jackie are you [ __ ]
kidding me right now like blowing me up
my spot up
like what about your speaking and I'm
hearing it like it's like I don't know
though like I don't know how to say this
to you but you like when it's about you
oh yeah I don't know you very self and
Bobby's about someone else all the time
right we're right but if I was in the
presence like what we said about
Bethenny like remember when her and Cara
were fighting because Carol wanted an
equal friendship and you just can't have
an equal friendship with someone like
Bethenny who was so the world revolves
around her so much better right and the
world truly revolves around Bethenny
like the world also revolves around the
Kardashians said if I was ever lucky
enough to me in the presence of the
Kardashians I would totally understand
that Jamie Lee I'm gonna say this and
now it's a compliment but like you are a
Bethenny no no I know I know I'm a
Bethenny but not in a world about how
she doesn't need another Bethenny Kylie
doesn't need another Kylie honestly she
needs a friend like me no I think change
listener I think she's so me I'm a great
listener I give great advice you do
actually the vault of Secrets
mostly because if you tell me something
you tell me not to tell anyone I don't
remember I will tell my brain to forget
it no I just naturally forget it
therefore I'm a great vault Christ oh
you're pregnant I didn't remember a big
lunch lunch I know I'm someone great
next story and in some equally shocking
news that was postponed until after
Zacky oh and I'm just so grateful Lady
Gaga and Christian Curry now call off
their engagement well I did say on the
toast like a week or two ago that I had
heard this so I just want to say I was
right yeah
the stars were an actress and her fiance
Christian Kareena have called off their
engagement her rep confirmed to people
on Tuesday Gaga and Kareena glad to be
out there in February 2017 just months
after she called off her engagement to
actor Taylor Kinney who was also her one
true love and the only man who will ever
be worthy of her love
except for maybe Bradley Cooper but he
seems busy right now and it's unclear
what is going on between them but you
know the fans still hold out hope yeah
and he's the type of guy who looks like
he would do the right thing and not
leave his baby mama so it looks like him
and Lady Gaga won't be stepping out
together anytime soon unfortunately for
us right but maybe in 18 years when the
kid has grown him and Lady IRA can
finally be together and experience true
love so only I'm 17 more years until we
can get Lady Gaga Bradley Cooper
together maybe just in time for another
remake of asteroids board
but until then Kareena was and it still
appears to be working as Gaga's CIA
agent when they coupled up in 2017 Gaga
gushed during one for concerts
in love with Kareena who is nearly 20
years her senior whoa he is who does it
look that old
yeah rumors swirled of an engagement for
them between them for a while but then
they Unsworth entrain to the Grammys and
like I mean obviously everyone thinks
that the reason that they're broken up
is because she's so head over heels in
love with Bradley Cooper and well I
don't know if that's necessarily true I
do think it's very odd to be engaged yet
in love with someone and then have such
visible physical and emotional chemistry
with someone else and you know I get
co-workers especially in the acting
world like you really need to have that
chemistry in order to vibe and make good
music and make it movies but this did
take it to a level that I was
uncomfortable with for I married for two
married people yeah and like I never
totally shipped Lady gaga and Christian
Kirino I only personally shipped Lady
Gaga's happiness and I don't know I just
didn't see it like I didn't see it there
um and I really do think that her and
Bradley Cooper like being in love is too
good to be true yeah so I'm not I don't
know that it's about that I wouldn't
love that but I would actually be
shocked if that turn out to be the case
yeah I don't think it's necessarily the
case I don't think Christian Kareena was
the man for her I do think she's maybe
one of those people especially like when
you're a woman who's so powerful rich
successful talented like their everyone
just wants something from you even if it
is someone who's equally like even if it
is another celebrity like I feel like
she's almost like Paris Hilton you know
just like boyfriends engaged but I don't
know will ever go through with it you
know yeah they both need a good
businessman beau they should talk to
Camille Graham international businessmen
beau yeah I don't know if I know anyone
who's single but I'll think about an
international that's right I think I
know a lot of national businessmen maybe
actually I know a couple regional
businessman but nothing global not yet
no we're we're getting there yeah well
this honestly while I'm sad for Lady
Gaga because I feel like she takes this
stuff like really not well and I think
that might be what we saw at the Grammys
I do hold out now a little bit more hope
for her and Taylor Kinney and I hold out
hope for an epic album oh yeah yes
selfishly like I said that she's going
through heartbreak but like I hope
there's a notebook next to her bad you
know yeah
I'm Taylor Kinney on the other side of
the bed or a typewriter she loves a
typewriter I feel like they could get
back together it's not like he's with
anyone she said that they said when they
broke up they're like this is really
meant just temporarily like our
schedules because he films Chicago PD
well like I just feel like
definitely get that up for her but and
like she's all over the world like it's
I feel like it's hard for a man they
don't want to like be like a groupie who
just follows and goes down but I think
Christian Kareena was more than happy to
do that but like she saw everything
really works for her ya know literally
like he was taking 10% and also like he
was like it's kind of like in Bohemian
Rhapsody when the guy who's like
managing he's like taking control of his
life and it's like maybe Taylor King
he's been trying to call Lady gaga a
Christian Kareena was hanging up the
phone right she's getting at her cell
phone Matt right and see all the
messages like like big sent all the
emails to Carrie but it was in that
folder but the password love um ya know
when they broke up they said it's like
it's temporary our schedules don't work
but I do think like it's like he should
just stop being so selfish and like give
up his fake acting career and just like
go on tour with her no I don't think she
could be with a man who would just you
know kowtow so easily to her I think
like she he's in Chicago in the police
force and like she's in Las Vegas right
now they're not so far from each other
she could take a jet to Chicago like
Chicago
well LA for 10 minutes yeah you know
like there's hope there I feel like it
was a love so great like they weren't
ready for it now like she truly has
conquered film music television like she
is ready to settle down with her
hometown hero Taylor Kinney I love him
so much
what is he even in that I know him from
other woman Oh gem of a man oh and
you're hooking up with Cameron Diaz oh
my god I forgot yes there's so many
things about the other one I'm having
coffee in front of the ocean in the
Hamptons yeah but the coffee table
she said you kick your feet up he's like
no and then they play that song mmm
sanitizing precious gem of a man oh my
god so funny so every morning I wake up
the same time that the dog walker comes
so when the doorbell rings like Theo
wakes up and he goes nuts flying but is
usually under the covers this morning he
was kind of like Dutch oven under the
under the blanket and he couldn't get
out so he flails and then he usually
gets out but he was flailing like easier
and he couldn't get out of the covers it
was so cute precious man yeah I love him
so much I can't believe he came to my
wedding like that was so cool
no but people are talk about all the
celebrities that worry right where are
your wedding and there's literally no
mention of the yeah it's crazy
private yeah people people actually
really respect how they were sexy it's
nice legendary designer Karl Lagerfeld
has died Karl Lagerfeld woman was
prolific and wildly popular designers of
the 20th and 21st centuries has died in
Paris he was 85 Lagerfeld was the
creative director of Chanel the French
house founded by Gabrielle Chanel for an
era defining age-defying 736 years upon
assuming the reigns in 1983 Lagerfeld
swiftly revived Chanel reinterpreting
the house founders iconic tweed skirt
suits little black dresses and quilted
handbags he did it via the lens of hip
hop one season in California California
surfer chicks the next he was a pop
culture of savant without ever
forgetting what the revolutionary Coco
stood for independence freedom and
modernity in more recent years as the
company's fortune grew and grew
Lagerfeld became known for the lavish
Grand Palais sets he conceived for the
sectional collections he designed a year
Wow
there was a rocketship a reproduction of
the Eiffel Tower and a super marche
stock strictly with Chanel brand
products
Florence welshing on the half-shell at
the spring 2012 show most memorable of
all was the improbable giant iceberg
from Scandinavia that Chanel shipped her
across the continent for the fall 2010
show Lagerfeld also pioneered the
concept of traveling priests out of
traveling pre season show the Karl
caravan has landed variously in
Versailles West Lothian Scotland Alice
Yule and spectacularly Havana Cuba um I
had no idea he was 85 like I don't know
when when I heard that he's adamant OD
to get in car accident like I didn't
think I actually caused it ya know it's
just it's so odd cuz I guess see when
you're like if you're having five you
can be so busy I know but that's what
happens when you wear sunglasses all the
time no one knows how well do you and
that's what I don't winter is trying to
do right and honestly it's a good move
cuz I honestly thought something
happened to him don't you feel like
every like model celebrity like fashion
icon is like being competitive on
Instagram like who can post the most
photos that look the most intimate with
her and Carl even though like Carl
probably hit it all that look the most
intimate and the most recent because
it's like you don't want 2009 photos
with car like so far what I've seen the
most intimate and looked like she really
didn't have the best relationship is um
Cara Delevingne for I don't follow her
so for me it was Kendall Jenner
this is really really sad he was and is
such a talent like this is a big loss
and
saying yesterday like the fashion world
I personally think it's struggling in
terms of creativity and now that two
houses have lost their helm chanel and
send me all their Carlitos it's just I
think this is just really sad it's the
end of an era I think I don't really get
how like fashion works like how can you
beat the designer for Chanel and Fendi
beats me no and I don't understand and
then also have your own line Karl
Lagerfeld that they sell at Macy's like
I just I do think that Karl Lagerfeld
the line was like the downfall of Karl
by Anthony Lee disagree I'm ago I was so
trashed oh my god I love Karl Lagerfeld
the line I mean it was so cheap oh my
god no that was what was so great about
it
it was all so cute and so Cara Lee and
it's like this carlito icon that he
created for Fendi but it's at prices
that are relatively a4 I'm gonna I still
I become the major designer of a huge
fashion house and make their staple item
a picture of you right and it's like so
goddamn cute in you're not even like a
cute man okay yourself a cute man
totally well Kris Jenner was up in there
with the pictures to like everyone is
just thirsting out did he have a funeral
yet I forget no don't okay so that'll be
like in the episode of sex of the city
when Javier dies and they all show up in
Javier
oh yeah I was more like a Gianni Versace
assassination they have the funeral and
the murderer is watching it on
PowerPoint it's great projector
projector power whatever Smart TV yeah
um I'm just I think this is really sad
he did so much great work everything
chanel Anthony has been so cute
everything is so ugly no everything else
is so ugly and I just hope that the
successor I forgot her name I hope that
she can keep it up yeah well you know
like everyone's just gonna critique it
cuz like it's hard to it's a hard tough
act to follow and like now I need to go
buy some Karl Lagerfeld line which I was
planning on doing anyway but I never got
around to stocks going up sucks going up
and prices I'm sure are going up too
because everything has Karl on it
totally I'd love that collection I love
that line I thought it was a genius
thing that he did because it was like
you feel like you're wearing Fendi but
just wearing Karl no totally but I just
saw it in like a poorly lit department
store once and I'm like this is not what
Karl Lagerfeld would've wanted no but it
is what he would have wanted also it's
like not everyone can afford Chanel can
afford penny the Karl Lagerfeld wants
the world to dress like they're wearing
Chanel and Benny but that's not
realistic so he made a line that made it
real
was sick I don't know he didn't seem
like the inclusive type kind of guy you
know I think he I mean he definitely was
you know inclusive for everyone except
for like forever skinny for acceptable
for average-sized women too um but I
think he really did want to see the
world be a more beautiful place and you
know he also realized that budgets can
be a concern no he probably went to like
a Broadway show and couldn't believe the
way people were dressing right oh my god
imagine he imagine if he ever flew coach
oh I feel like he's the type really
doesn't leave his town you know yeah his
town of Paris yes like Belle yes just
stuck in a over no good memories he
looks like Maurice making little knit
sweaters well very sad rest in peace
Karl Lagerfeld very sad another story
that's just weird as hell [ __ ] wild
jussie Smollett faces prison career ruin
if he lied about attack we haven't we
haven't had a chance to talk about the
updates and the jussie Smollett we
reported one nasty Smollett gate we
reported wouldn't happen and like
everyone like I just couldn't believe it
I'm like this is horrible shock dismay
sadness shame terrible and now I have
all of those feelings the opposite well
we're here there were like murmurs that
it wasn't true and I think everyone was
like a little like nervous even like
journalists whose priority should be
just like getting the facts telling even
they were like I don't think I can say
unless like 100% this is true because if
it's what we think it is like holy [ __ ]
right and even the police wouldn't
confirm because it's like yes all these
facts are looking like it's not sure but
we're not gonna [ __ ] say that because
what if what if it it like you can't you
have it has to be a hundred percent sure
in order for you to put that idea out
there so the fact that it's out there
everyone is talking about it but look if
you're gonna accuse the victim of a hate
crime a heinous one of actually staging
the hey grandma you better have receipts
right and honestly we still don't have
receipt we have receipt I would you okay
yeah
Josie smell it is facing prison time and
the implosion of his career if it turns
out he lied about being the target of a
hate crime legal and public relations
experts say the best thing that
care about what the legal and public
relations experts have to say I want to
care about the facts so just get the
receipts I'm on it I'm going back to
page six I don't know why and I don't
know why I [ __ ] with variety in the
first place and like the day that it
started to unravel was maybe the day
after he went on GMA and was interviewed
by Robin what's-her-name
she's my name under Robin yes she's it's
Robin on GMA um and then to watch that
interview through the lens of he's
making it up you see like the real actor
in him come out you know I mean the
weirdest thing is when she's like why
don't you just hand over your phone like
great question Robin things like the
police are trying to help you find and
he's like and I totally understand like
the privacy thing like there are things
on my phone I wouldn't want seeing but
like what he was saying is like I have
private voice notes songs that I've
written I'm like I get the images lucky
I got a tittie pic you know like I get
it but voice notes Reno but it's like
you're gonna forsake your titty pic and
let the the perpetrators get away just
because you don't want someone to see a
private photo no but that's not everyone
who say he was saying his private voice
nice and so on but he rather someone not
here is his private Robin Roberts is
heard Oh Robin right and I got and then
I was gonna say Robin McGee
Robyn Lawley favorite the model
oh yeah no not her okay cops
investigating tip Jesse small it was
seen with the brothers the night of the
alleged attack the brothers who are
being who are being questioned as
suspects in the attack Chicago police
received a tip on Tuesday that Jesse
smell it and the two brothers connected
to his alleged hate attack were spotted
together around the same time of the
beatdown a tipster called police saying
they believe they may be Empire star
with the brothers in an elevator at
North water apartments where the actor
lives possibly after the assault
happened on January 29th detectives were
sent this morning to validate that tip
and investigated they are investigating
it it is unconfirmed we haven't
validated it it's like they are covering
their tracks
yeah um police spokesman said
investigators plan to interview the man
but later on Tuesday the police
spokesperson said in a tweet that the
tip was false on the trio were not in
the elevator gather CBD has confirmed
that a tip okay there's just all these
competing reports what we know is that
the brothers who
enacting this attack and is attack
allegedly yeah we're allegedly we're
friends of Jessie's foj had worked on
the show Empire yeah W okay yes me and
had worked out with him in his building
according to Instagram and they were
friends they have been they were seen
together a few days before they attack
like this is the thing if you're gonna
go and staged your own hate crime like
you cannot be this messy Jessie like we
should just call you nothing because
that's what you [ __ ] are like hanging
out the day before on it's red leaving
photo proof how [ __ ] stupid are you
someone in the comments were that he was
the one who bought the rope when I'm
talking hard there's an actual receipt
like let's see get your [ __ ] together
and stop being so goddamn rights because
if you're gonna stage a hate crime you
have to do it my [ __ ] better okay I'm
so angry for so many reasons like one
channel me hate crimes like actually do
happen and like nobody talks about them
on the level that Jesse's got spoken
about and those people get doubted like
oh you're making it up know there's this
here's someone who actually is making it
up and now he's gonna validate those
people who are like oh you're making
that up
like that's annoying first of all second
of all how emotionally invested I was I
was literally refreshing my Twitter like
when I heard this I'm like this is the
most horrible story I've ever heard like
I'm so angry like end of the day like I
guess I'm happy that a hate crime didn't
happen like that's good but my dad at
that place as we thought it was it's
this is worse I'm like are you this is
this is sick like I went to bed last
night
and I prayed I'm like I hope musty smell
it gets the help he needs because
seriously no more jokes like only a sick
[ __ ] thinks of this okay I know but
that's why I almost hope that it's that
this isn't that he didn't make it
because this is worse no this is weirder
like this is more control what would you
never around more would be more shocking
it's musty smell it fake this attack
if Kim Kardashian is working with
fashion Oba or if Jordan would stuff
with Jason Thompson
what's the most shocking that like musky
smell it like this is this is next-level
like for living rabbits like no it's I'm
sorry it's really not funny I'm only
living at the musty Parkers I thought
it's not funny like this is horrifying
like I can't believe and then I really
they rehearsed it okay when I woke up
that morning I was like horrified that
we lived in a world where people could
think to even act upon these bigot risks
feelings I don't know if that's word
bigoted feelings right now this morning
I woke up where I'm horrified to live in
a world where there are people who think
it's funny or smart or whatever to fake
a hate crime like what a loser what a
[ __ ] loser he now takes the cake
he's taken the metal flap of Maria
Menounos his head I'm putting it on his
own neck I am the number one loser in
this group okay user total loser also
but I feel like no one has actually
confirmed either way like which it is
and then I was like now because it's
like no one wants to be the person to
say that he makes it just because if
you're wrong about this like it's
career-ending much like staging your own
hate crime right but he also hasn't has
he spoken since people have started to
doubt him oh I'm not sure and he
addressed the doubters also the dress in
that interview have to watch it
absolutely the day before his [ __ ] cup
blown up and he's acting so hard and he
addressed the doubters the there's more
facts on the story and I just wanted to
report the facts because it's like
that's what we have to this is a very
news heavy story and that's what we have
to do as journalists ok the Cook County
State's Attorney has recused herself
from the case oh my god honestly I
wouldn't want to be involved so much
like Chuck Rhodes should have done Cook
County State's Attorney Kim Fox's recuse
County State Attorney Kim Bucks
has recused herself on the investigation
by Chicago authorities into Jessie small
to lights attack out of an abundance of
caution that's what this is an abundance
of caution not even the police not even
investigators want to be the person to
confirm that this was staged the
decision to recuse herself was made to
address potential questions have been
partially based upon familiarity with
potential witnesses in the case
so I guess she's she's tampered then
there's more stories
oh so people were saying that um he did
this heat because he was going to get
written off of the show but then the
writers of empire tweeted that he was
never
written off the show so why did he do
this no they said that he at this moment
isn't being written off because when
people started to doubt him they're like
oh we're getting him off Empire cuz he
staged it and then Empire was like no we
never said that oh it's all so blurry
and gray and I don't understand it's so
crazy another one ABC staffers doubted
Jesse smollett's attack story ABC
employees were duteous about Jesse's
mom's alleged racist and homophobic
assualt immediately following his
interview with Robin Roberts a new
report says staffers who were president
for the exclusive sit-down with GMA
hosts felt the truth behind smell its
story was up in the air source has told
the blast a source told the Post that
the interview came about because the
Empire star was adamant about appearing
on GMA he specifically requested that
Roberts handle the intermediate wheel
because the two knew each other from
when she appeared on an episode of
Empire that aired in April I love our
Robert she's so dynamic small has
claimed he was attacked in Chicago on
January 29th but suspicions have
surfaced that he paid two brothers to
stage the assault the veteran
broadcaster probes smile at about his
lead allegations in many different ways
during the interview that aired but he
maintained that he was a victim during
the sit down smell and also tamp down
doubts over the his account of what
happened at first it was the thing of
like listen if I tell the truth and
that's because it's the truth he said at
the time then it became a thing of like
how can you doubt that how can you not
believe that it's the truth on Monday
Roberts addressed the growing
controversy surrounding smullins story
when I sat down with Jesse it was
Tuesday night in Chicago at the time to
give his first account publicly give his
first account of what he said it
happened at that time on Tuesday police
officers were saying that his account
was consistent it was credible in that
he was being cooperative
now this was all before the interview
aired on Thursday and then we found out
about the brothers a grand jury will
begin hearing evidence as early as
Tuesday that could result in felony
charges against smut I guess it'll be up
to a grand for a jury to decide if you
see or not state [ __ ] or not wow that's
crazy you know I was just watching Law &
Order like a couple days ago and it's
like all these things are always left to
a jury like the jury like never does the
right thing I never hear about a jury
swiftly serving justice it's always like
oh they jury the jury the jury the jury
was bribed the jury did this the jury
was wrong it's like the jury system I
feel like was put in place I don't know
chili do it the most fair just way and
like it never works out that way
I've also never been on a jury and it
ends the next time I got call for jury
duty I'm gonna try and go through with
jury I'm doing jury duty in March yeah
and I I don't I feel like you would be a
very rural juror oh my god so [ __ ]
worried about row with urban forever
right no I do actually think you have a
good way of seeing the other side always
like when I come in here with a thought
about Beverly Hills how so I was like
you always play like like the other side
and I'm like damn she's right you know
like I do you think you have a very fair
and balanced look at the world and they
do you think it would be a good juror
well thank you we'll see what the courts
decide in March also feds are now
questioning interesting smell it sent a
threatening letter to himself remember
there was yes there was a got a serial
killer letter magazine cutouts I know
they found magazines in his apartment
okay that's not real evidence unless the
letters were cut out like that does not
count right so it's all just up in the
air and we need to get into recapping TV
but just one there's six stories because
Serena Williams in Amala Clooney
co-hosted Megan Markos baby shower this
weekend in New York City Oh Serena
Williams mm-hmm she had the Royal
Wedding yes okay
on Wednesday Serena Williams and Amal
Clooney will co-host the afternoon event
oh it's today oh yeah pep mark hotel
yeah I know let's go that's why we got
cancelled arm did you know that oh yes
our meeting that we got all dressed up
for was canceled because Megan's in town
and then someone else was sick whatever
um
cute yeah I feel like obviously all the
celebrity friends besides for Priyanka
Chopra that showed up to the wedding are
all more orchestrated like through the
the palace tour like here's who we want
her to be friends with in Hollywood they
really chose like the top of the top
like Serena Williams the greatest
athlete of all time like the female of
like just everything perfect um all of
humanitarian folk married I had an
arranged marriage to a Jonas Brother who
the Jonas Brothers are getting back
together yeah that's why I mean I don't
care they said like after a six-year
Feud like they're always hanging out
yeah they have like a good family
relationship and I think they have a
good working relationship no whew yeah I
don't know they're like a six-year
hiatus off of huge feud you know it and
that I'm not gonna participate and give
life so this is and now it would make
sense why they were thirsting out their
wedding actually know what I can't judge
people for the buzz about their wedding
the totally the Jonas Brothers reunion
is is fact it's not rumor anymore no no
but like now it makes
why they were being so crazy that the
wedding in like binding Kenichi I back
into the publicly whatever this says for
making what this says for the day out
and the bed right there good man back
together right
so just something okay so much TV was on
this week me to get a chance to recap
yesterday's we literally didn't have
time to breathe but let's talk about it
Monday nights are always good Vanderpump
rules in The Bachelor I did not watch
The Bachelor because I was so [ __ ]
tired from your wedding like the thought
of making myself even more emotionally
like mentally tired was just too much
for me I ain't much of a stir because I
didn't want to think about anything
other than my wedding like I didn't want
to get involved into anything else but I
did watch fandom from pearls cuz I get
so much enjoy I look forward when I see
it in my DVR I'm like oh happy day
that's not how I feel about honestly
that's only how I feel about Bravo shows
and I think about it cuz I don't really
feel that way about she has two key
anymore
no okay one time five Vanderpump girls
because it was not a good episode really
it took me about five hours to get
through the whole thing it was a lot of
breaks no and nothing happened once
again and whatever was happening with
Christine there was something going on
that no one was taught they weren't it
was like they were talking about
something that was happening without
telling us what was happening was so
vague I hate what I do there and I was
like so not interested but in any of it
I did like the episode for two reasons
because I think it was the episode of
realizing stuff for me yes I think when
it comes to the Kristen and James saying
there was something they wasn't they
weren't telling us but Christine made a
really good point
she's like James has done horrible
things and literally gets fired multiple
times and always somehow coups his way
she said what Barry did she said what um
what murder did her and him and Lisa
commit that he's so he gets such special
treatment and she's like I got fired for
saying suck a dick and like if she was
crazy a couple years ago but everyone
gets fired and rehired like she got
fired and was never allowed back she's
not even like allowed into Tom Tom like
she really got like the [ __ ] end of the
stick where it's like some could say
like she's doing what James is doing but
James keeps coming back his brothers
coming his mom's coming James comes back
his ba-doing town Tommy's doing the
detail email party like I would be
[ __ ] annoyed if I was Christians you
because it's not the job at Sur it's
what comes with the job at Sur it's like
being a full-time cast member like James
keeps getting back whereas Kristen was
fired and that was it like the end-all
be-all and not like she really even
tried to come back but still like I
would be pissed you know I Lisa is NASA
and she's especially cruel towards
Kristen but then Kristen behaves like
she did in last night's episode and it's
like no wonder you weren't invited to a
party at Tom town because Lisa could
argue like that could have happened that
Tom Tom know she's a crazy drunk and
whatever but when it came to the James
thing and everyone's like she's in love
with James or whatever like I don't
think it has anything to do with James
it's like look what she gave James she
made James and James get such special
treatment whereas like she got fired and
that was a that Lisa show me turn like
she's an adult grown woman she needs to
realize that by letting James affect her
like this it makes her more of the
person that they don't like like she
needs to rise above it Katie said get
over it get the [ __ ] like you know she's
got sorry we're enough yet to figure
that but she has come so far she really
has and I and I feel for her but like
she does not help herself even though
she's been doing everything right like
she takes a million step back spents
backward in episodes like last night and
like proves everyone right about her
yeah but like I don't know I'm just not
so quick to like hop on the bandwagon
like I think when Katie was on the phone
with Carter she was being so rude to
Carter and like your girlfriend's an
embarrassment like that's me and yeah it
was just it was all weird but I also
didn't care because like I didn't
understand what was going on
maybe I wasn't paying close enough
attention but it's like she goes head
tide she texts Carter she comes back
inside and she's being a monster yeah we
never got to hear what actually happened
on the text but then Stassi dropped a
truth bomb and you could tell she really
forgot she was on camera cuz the second
she said it she like freaked out because
it's obviously like this unspoken thing
like Carter lives off of Kristen Kristen
pays the bills Kristen does everything
it's not like Kristen's a main character
so wife if she doesn't get all the perks
why should she have to air her dirty
laundry right and that's what she said
on watch tremens live so someone called
in it was like how are you and Carter
like now watching these episodes isn't
it awkward and she was like honestly
like I bleed out for the show that's
what she said she said I've never not
been open book I don't want to talk
about it right now because we're not
doing well basically alluding to the
fact that they weren't together I mean I
don't know how you could watch this
episode and next week's episode let's
see what she says about him and and
about her friends say about him and not
have problems what a piece of [ __ ]
though I know it's just I really thought
they were like like they were perfect
for each other like he was the guy she
needed yeah and but what Stassi
if you don't want to pay for anything
and like you want to be a freeloader but
at least just be nice you know like
because that's fair like since every
situation is different like she
definitely does well from the show from
Instagram whatever and maybe he doesn't
and so she's in a position to pay for
everything and that really is fine but
no but when I in this side commentator
when she was like he's a photographer's
assistant like I wanted to die oh my god
I do a lot of real-time that that that's
what he did yeah honestly no one ever
like probed into their relationship
right because he she was barely a
character and then he was really not
even a focal point and then the way that
they like come to all these things it
seems like they're just like copacetic
but honestly I'm here for for them
diving into people who don't work at Sur
because I would like to move as far away
from Sur as possible like I can't stand
those scenes anytime Lisa's at the
restaurant like it's so boring and so
uninteresting and I just I don't have
the managed care it'll brother like
learning how to pick up cups like I'm
good yeah so but then the other thing I
realized it was like the night of like I
thought I had I was set in my ways I'm
like Kristen's crazy Sheena's annoying
but I kind of was like with feeling for
scheana like I don't know I feel like
she's definitely not who she says she is
like she plays his person on the show
but like what I saw I was like I felt so
bad they were like asking your question
she's like Lala just told me to stop
talking now you're like asking me
personal [ __ ] where it's like I text you
to braid my hair and like you don't even
answer like why should I tell you on
camera like about my sex life even
though she has been telling everyone
like no she was just it was like she
took wow is it loud his advice was like
stop she took it too literally yes I
love was like stop making everything
about yourself you know like because
it's uncomfortable yeah and then she was
asked about herself and that's when you
speak about yourself when you're asked
you know so it was like she doesn't know
how to be a human so she was like don't
speak about Sogeti then I thought too
but then she made a good point she was
like you not we never talked like you
don't talk to me like I texted you like
I'm in my room by myself but then you're
asking me like a personal question like
that's weird for me no but that's how
you that's how you get like builds
friendships like they're together now
okay here we are now yes we have this in
the past but what's going on with you I
heard you go up to put Adam tell me
about that oh and by the way you tell
everyone about it yes not like you're
super private you literally like would
scream it from the rooftops if you could
I just thought for the first time Sheena
was making some valid points she was let
and then Katie was like I'll never
forget what you said to me
it's like when they did a flashback it's
like Tom quebra Sheena and then Sheena
came back for Tom like let's be real
like we have to give credit where
credit's you and Sheena's just painted
as a Senoia and she is like she's
annoying for sure but I don't think she
has bad intentions and I felt bad for
look she's on this trip with all these
people who don't like her and her one
friend like went to the other side
Ariana Stassi staying in a room together
like I feel bad for her
uh you know what I don't think it's like
that and this is what I think it is and
by the way that fight between scheana
and Tom Schwartz is a nothing fight I
know but they're talking about it that's
the reason their friendship is fractured
this is what I think happens
I think they film the show scheana is
fake and you know only lets people see
what she wants them to see the girls are
tired of it they stopped filming she
moves to Vegas she does her so she never
speaks them she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about them when they're not filming then
they start filming again and she comes
back and she and while she's been over
here and they're all having real
friendships and Rises and maybe she even
keeps in touch with Lala and Ariana
because like they're her friends but
then she comes back to filming and she
one seen on The Witches of WeHo and and
they're like no look we're all friends
and you're fake and you actually don't
even care about us outside of this show
and that's what I think it is and then
they could have to go on the trip and
it's awkward because they're all best
friends and now they're with this
stranger well I'm just trying to watch a
show that I'm watching I don't and I
just when I got that for her
I'm the reunion last year lava and she
looked you know we're not getting along
because she and I moved to Vegas for her
show and she just left
Lila high and dry like whatever reach
out or anything so I can't even imagine
how she treated Katie Kristen and Stassi
who she's not even friends with yeah so
I think it's like that it's like she's
fake that their show is really about
their friendship and the family of
friends that they've created and scheana
is just not a part of that and she only
wants to be when they're filming because
she's fake and she loves television but
when they're not filming she goes into
us her other thing with the Batchelor
people being thirsty and Adam and Robbie
Hayes I don't know that's what I think
is going on I'm saying is that I feel
bad for let's talk about boys night
jabbering Jack acting like a rocket in
the rock house so literally nailed the
hit the nail on the head like Jax is
like please you've done so much whereas
now you're sitting next to her like
Rihanna I got a already what yet but
I'll show you chill the [ __ ] out
I'm the gun if prenta Hittle on that
said the Hat burn totally he was looking
so guilty and like it just was so weird
yeah and he's like riling the girls have
been and nothing's going on no he made
that whole situation like so crazy on
like across the state of California
except it doesn't take five guys to get
Peter magically like he's fine no Peter
Madrigal is totally fine that party
looked like so sad like and pathetic
with like the mirror and like why can't
uncle taught drinking around random
girls
I don't know Tom Schwartz like was I was
not feeling him in the episode like also
he he was acting borderline
inappropriate and nobody like cared so
so was Tom's and of all the times I know
it was like in it for the cocktail see
that Tom Sandoval was very clear minded
yeah Tom Schwartz get so wasted and like
just puts himself in bad situation it's
like no one ever wonders this Tom
Sandoval gonna cheat on Ariana cuz he
doesn't have that issue but like Tom
Schwartz has that issue and he should've
been on the balcony freaking out Jack's
right not taking drinking patron out of
the bottle even though they shot that
from three different angles and
pretended it was three different shots
yeah but still shouldn't have even been
one shot drink the [ __ ] beer don't
drink it all no I agree
it was honestly being a class act yeah
James is weird
he is weird just because I know what I
know about him in today right as I was
watching the show and there was no
social media I would be honestly like
rooting for her James comeback but
knowing that he like went to the Super
Bowl to play a DJ gig at a party and
like he couldn't even do it because he
was so drunk like yeah that was him you
know for me why have they like held
Peter at this distance like he has like
one episode per season where he's like
somewhat relevant in the storyline but
like for the most part like it is
usually his birthday like he I wonder if
he wants to be a full time like what
well how has he gotten himself into this
position I don't know I don't mind it
though no me neither and he really is
like the authority figure and so he
really can't be like in the weeds with
everyone like getting [ __ ] up because
he's supposed to be their boss right and
also maybe they did try and like put him
in more [ __ ] little stuffy and and he
didn't test well or something yeah he's
right it's a haircut too he's kind of
boring well I thought it was good
episode lots to unpack I thought they
keep stewing though god damn you're
doing the same thing teasing that was so
trashed and they did it with Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills show they
tease this one moment as if it's like
the center of the episode when it's
literally the
asked two minutes they did that in
Beverly Hills - on the plane they ended
on the plane
yeah but all they did was oh she's a
snoring problem and that was literally
the last ten second episodes and Gus
[ __ ] that [ __ ] she lets go to Beverly
Hills um okay Beverly Hills
I um really not much of anything they
plan to go on the trip the trip was
really interesting it was sponsored by
Baha Mar like not one of the hotels like
the community the plane that said Baha
Mar right that's where we seed I know no
but we stayed at a hotel in Baha Mar but
it's a it's a three hotel where creme
saying like not one of the hotels
sponsored it like the whole gated
community spot sponsored it yeah that's
like saying like Nassau you know no you
know but it's not that cuz it's like
there's SLS bottom arm that rosewood but
they're all in the same complex it'd be
like saying Oh Mayakoba I don't know
what that is
it's the same thing in Mexico it's like
it's a big property with three hotels
and like villas it's like a gated case
in my coma I just thought it was
interested tourism board I mean that's
not yeah it's not a city but usually
it's just either sponsored by like a
hotel it's just I just thought it was
interesting yeah it was and I was
thinking when they were flying plane is
that I didn't realize Lisa Vanderpump
did go on the trip because all of the
pictures I didn't see her in anything I
was following that trip like mad a lot
it it's so weird when they stay out like
a pop in hotel because this in the
middle of dinner they're in the middle
of a restaurant right and toasters with
videos yeah so that's so funny also I
want her I want to know if they address
a video went viral of a lady chasing
down to read asking her to pay back the
money that she owes to this guy Ryan or
whatever and like she just brushed it
off and kept walking to the pool but I
wonder if that it all becomes a part of
the show because I don't think they got
it on camera yeah there's a lot of
shadiness like with Dury there is more
than morning and it's like I really hope
it's not true because I really like her
now and I hate watching the people that
I like I go through financial room
because it's like me too
I love you you know and I'm now
following on Instagram still but like
that's not why I watch Real Housewives
to watch like you know financial
struggles like it's it's aspirational
right I mean I love Joey but the hair
that she's been rocking in these so
terrible terrible but I don't care cuz
she's making bad hair choices but good
friendship choices keeps going out to
lunch with Lisa Rinna and Erika Jayne
like the three of them three best
friends we saw that starting last at the
end of last season at the Beverly
thing but now it's just taking on like a
whole new life I love them together they
hung out with Denise okay what I am NOT
here for Denise
she's very boring she's so boring and I
guess you have been like in order to be
interested in Denise like you have to be
obsessed with Charlie Sheen and maybe
he's like this major figure that people
like are obsessed with because they talk
about him like she's married to the
president or she was they get him on the
phone it's nice sex it's Charlie Sheen
Charlie sounded very normal time she did
this he sounded normal and like I don't
care about Charlie Sheen so therefore I
don't care about this storyline but but
she was worth bringing on the season the
four million they paid her just for the
Nicollette Sheridan of it all when okay
so he was talking about how he's still
going through this like treacherous
divorce and then Lisa Rinna was like oh
you know Harry was actually married to
that woman and then they didn't say her
name at first and then when Lisa Rinna
said Nicholas Sheridan who was on
dynasty as Alexis and was any Briton
Desperate Housewives like I died and
when Lisa Rinna was literally like I
mean I love Michael Bolton she went oh
Michael Bolton concert her never came
home
right she said that before she was like
I think mostly Michael Bolton for my
life every day oh you're AB hysterical
who is she married to now Nicollette
Sheridan anyone oh I'm not sure I had no
idea she was married to Harry Hamlin and
now I'm like what's what's her fiance's
name Aaron Aaron I'm like Aaron hello a
first I just thought he was like some
guy who works at a clinic right same I
thought he was like a back breaker
masseuse but uh that was so crazy that
in and of itself was worth her time on
the season totally I mean you know what
they need to do next Nicola Sharon needs
to become a house 100% especially
because I have heard she is a [ __ ]
nightmare nutjob but yeah I have heard
horrible things at her from the set of
Desperate Housewives but also to dynasty
I heard they want to replace her I heard
they are replacing her and according to
like the last episode of dynasty like
she's nosy oh no nothing I mean but it's
like she's she's there's nothing she
beleve nothing left there for her um so
that was great
I hate I just they take so long to get
to everything it's like the trip is now
next week it's like I thought the trip
was this because we saw them on the
plane yeah and it's very early for them
to be going on a trip I what if they're
gonna go on more than one I think they
needed to bring everything together
because everyone's filming separately
because like Lisa Vanderpump one won't
go to the cooking class I'm here in his
house what happened this week I
literally can't remember they made those
chocolate hearts are those
that guy was hot Amelie there was a lot
of talk about body image and anorexia
and eating disorders oh there was and it
would seem to me a common theme like
that and that then and when Eric oak
said I have to stop eating for babies
yes I feel like there's gonna be some I
mean perhaps Lisa Rinna is gonna be like
start an organization where she like
raises awareness for this but it felt
like it was leading us towards something
greater so in this conversation cuz then
it was all I became aware of what's the
way they were talking about their body I
couldn't agree more but I was having
like a dementia moment because I
remember when Amelia posted on Instagram
and I didn't think for some reason what
is that illness that Gigi Hadid Gigi has
yeah it's I don't know it sounds
Japanese the name it's like hi yeah
Harry showed Harry moto know whatever I
thought that when Amelia posted that she
said that she had that disorder not an
in disorder but maybe I'm confused I
think she posted twice in about two
separate things cuz I remember when she
posted about her eating disorder and it
was like really brave and like great for
her and it's really nice to see like her
actually on the other side of it just
like talking about how like worried she
has about other people that are
struggling with it
but I do feel like Hashimoto's is the
name Hashimoto's I feel like it's
leading us towards something bigger for
this group of women in terms of eating
disorders but it's like it's so and when
they were saying they were like
Hollywood this industry is so terrible
and me and everyone else is doing fine
and it's like we project this image but
the rest of the world is actually you
know doing better than we are together
and I still feel that way it's like the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills are
telling us about everybody and it's just
like you guys are the ones who purport
these images you know and or the
industries that your your family is
working like right you know it's it's
kind of are we interesting I'll be
interested to see what they do with it
ya know it was a very food heavy episode
and I totally forgot about that scene
with Kathryn Edwards we're at Lisa like
freaked out and I guess it's because
like her kid was at the time probably
going through it but when that was a
really long time ago I was like because
everyone always accuses Lisa Rinna of
having me because she's so screaming and
she said I'm just like this but I think
she's so sensitive to it because like
she's seen other people yeah she's been
in industry for a long time she has seen
some [ __ ] I'm sure um but when Amelia
Grace had done she said I saw a mom and
daughter and they were just like looked
so bad and I didn't know what she was
talking about at first I'm like where is
this going what do you mean because the
way she started the conversation she
she's like I was getting a manicure and
I saw this mom and daughter I'm like she
was in bad shape and I thought it was
like homeless I didn't end literally
nobody's talking about that part did you
pay attention to any of this TV show I
guess not I don't know they were just
weren't compelling it feels like they
just made my concussion oh my god
usually they decide to go on a trip and
then they just go but like they decided
in the first minute to on a trip at the
lunch with Lisa Rinna and to read Erica
and then like took so long to get there
right in and Erica may or may not have a
house in Lake Tahoe that was hilarious
she didn't think we have a place there
to actually I loved her I thought that's
where they're going I'm like Lake Tahoe
you know they could do better you know I
heard like - I was so nice yeah let me
show you out
totally Muhammad if I hum are still
sponsoring people in sending claims like
I'm dying to go back meet you we had
such a good time time we're gonna do an
anniversary trip oh that's a good idea
right yeah same crew same crew love it
except we could like trim a little bit
yeah an adverb in oh yeah what else oh
I'm having dementia moment even though I
was watching like I watched not much
happening like really
there was no shadiness they brought up
dog gate again clearly that's coming to
a head Lisa Vanderpump is being an
[ __ ] on the plane and she's clearly
treating treat like she usually treats
Kyle Richards yeah Oh Kyle's has another
daughter to go into college I just oh
yeah I can't tell you how I don't care
Kyle though pretty much on the plane in
one word one line is summed up the
entire season it's all fun and games
until one jab goes too far that's really
what it is like Lisa and her British
humor ah then she says something it's
like really [ __ ] evil and conniving
and she's like it's British humour
I'm excited to see what happens next
week when they're like if you cross Lisa
Vanderpump there's no going back
notes that the tide is turning and there
the girls are starting to get into
formation and it has to be really bad if
they're gonna come for her when she's
clearly going through a lot you know
yeah we can't even excuse it but you
know what and I said this last week and
when people are when someone's going
through something they automatically had
a pass but I think it's important that
we not forget a few seasons ago when
Eileen Davidson was suffering in silence
grieving the loss of her mother didn't
talk about it at all and Erica was I
mean Lisa was so mean to her sorry
just sayin and then delivered a weird
sorry in the middle of a party like a
season later remember yeah and Eileen
was like I let her had no idea what she
was talking about cuz it was so late
yeah I remember that I'm just
so looking back Eileen yeah sure she
doesn't want to come back I'm so she
doesn't but they were playing two
seasons ago before the new episode last
night so all day I was watching and it
was just so refreshing
I love Eileen David because I hate when
her and Lisa Rinna came on and that's
what I'm feel about the recent Richards
right now it's like you got all this
respect automatically because you're
someone but it's like in the real
housewives world you're no one to me
Charlie Sheen is in no one to me but you
know what's so funny it's like I think
more than any franchise Beverly Hills
really it has gets really like
successful women in many different
fields like soap opera daytime
television restaurant or real estate the
agency like they really Erika Jayne pop
star like they they've covered all the
genres yeah because I think it's an
attractive career path for now people
whose career options are dwindling which
is fine Nicolette chard and should
really give in yeah and a lot of these
women like it's not like others show
other cities where it's kind of you
become disgraced a little bit yeah they
are elevated by it like Kyle Richards is
elevated by the show Lisa Vanderpump
Erika Jayne everyone like unless you're
I'm trying to even think who was the
last person who was like Adrienne Maloof
maybe like had a bad experience ending
well hopefully this season Lisa
hopefully you know of all the people to
like cut ties with the network her with
the show I'll be most interested to see
how Lisa's plays out I've heard that
she's thinking about not going to the
reunion but she's still so tied to the
network through venom from pearls but
here's how I see it going ideally Lisa
Vanderpump doesn't show up to the
reunion she's disgraced everyone hates
her if they cut her off they changed the
name of the show to pump roles and it's
just about this group of people who used
to work at a restaurant owned by Lucy
van in front but no longer is associated
with restaurants but now TomTom has kept
us tied tilt Lisa Vanderpump for a few
more years that was her master plan yeah
but they could still cut it they could
be like I'm going time gone by
she'll still be an executive producer
she'll still make money but she doesn't
like own the show like she used to
however the reunion has not been filmed
yet so she could still show up yeah but
she doesn't change she's a lot of things
Lisa Vanderpump
but she's not accountable like she does
not like to sit and apologize and I feel
like for the most part and in order to
be a good housewife you have to know
when it's time to go dig your heels in
and attack but also retreat and
apologize and just own your [ __ ] like
everyone has to have a small amount and
if you're the type of person who can
only attack
and not own their [ __ ] that doesn't a
good housewife make and Lisa Vanderpump
has made a career off of literally like
always being on the side that's right
technically but I think tides are
shifting and she might she just might
have to apologize you know I don't know
if she could do it we'll see but a lot
can happen in real life between now and
then one like people you know talk and
the show airs and things are said and
you know Doreen might see something that
she doesn't like about Kyle and then
call Lisa and be like I'm back we're
right yeah so you never that's what
happened when we almost got a turn on
Lisa bad if I'm throw me to the wolves
and I'll return leading the pack
Kyle was there but in the reunion she
spun around and went back home almost
almost she's still paying the piper for
it she really is she has two key um this
show has become very frustrating to
watch the opening scene was impossible
because I like I'm for me this is
Juliet's key like I am here to watch
Juliet and her friends and Juliet's
happiness like Romeo and Juliet and to
watch Alex talk to her and treat her
like that and watch her take it and like
be so she's David it really it's not
enjoyable and then I was thinking and
then Kara comes on with Garrett and you
know what they're being kind of cute and
cowardly was really at somewhere I'm
sorry that thigh thing was so [ __ ]
stupid and no I thought it was like so
realistic it's like okay she's obviously
self-conscious
she's dating a personal trainer who's in
perfect shape and she feels like okay he
put he squeezes that and all he sees is
fat because that's how he thinks
I totally related to her I'm sorry I
thought it was so stupid and she was
being nuts no I thought she was being
just like a real person and like yeah it
must be hard to date someone who's in
perfect shape
well I'm sure Ben feels right so anyways
that was a gimmick carrots Kara's kind
of cute and then it's like we are
defending Julia to the death and I will
continue to you because I love her just
yeah but it's really inviting me of the
season of real houses of New Jersey when
Melissa came on and she did nothing
wrong and we all took Theresa side just
because we've loved Theresa and we're
like yeah Melissa stinks get her out but
now in hindsight it's like we were all
so mean to Melissa when all she did was
just come on the show and have rational
thoughts and be a decent Russian and
that's how I feel like like what I did
was be Theresa's sister like Oh Julia
continues to blow up on Kara when it has
nothing to do with Karen yes and when
she needs to be taking it out on Alex
and like I feel like we'll watch this
season back in hindsight up in Lake
Juliette was dead wrong and she Kara's
totally fine no I don't I don't dislike
Kara as it relates back to Juliet I just
don't like Kara like I have so many
apartments I think I want to be here
like there's just so many people I just
want to slap her honestly I want I hate
everyone in the show how about that
no like I just accept I like Madison's
boyfriend he's cute
oh and I want him she shouldn't have
done that music video and he should hook
up with the bartender no he should hook
up with someone not that girl she is
trash yeah sorry yeah her eyes are so
blue her whole thing is that she has
going on is terrible lashes are so he
needs to go back
he needs to fly to New York and find a
nice Jewish girl to settle down with
buying million dollar home what about
snitch that house was nice that house
wasn't saying you know what Chloe is
gonna be pissed at Madison if she sends
him packing yeah Chloe was out here
Chloe's [ __ ] hilarious I know I love
her and it's like Chloe keeps the show
moving Juliette was in an uber home and
Chloe brought her right back no Chloe ya
know when Juliet was like coming to the
bar actually that was so funny I've
actually never done that that is so
funny and and I love so Julian and Chloe
for me are just like I love it and I'm
loving Kelsey's you know she's taking a
back seat for now she's gonna build back
up you know I lost a see she was she's
gonna come back strong swelling abroad
she realizes you know she's taking back
scene and I'm really feeling her but I
just I love Julian and khloe and khloe
is just being you know the character
that the producers need her to be ya
know the show couldn't move forward and
have a life cycle without Chloe know it
would take weeks of episodes for for
Julia to see that picture and then she
would be getting upset over something
that I've moved on from right you know
that was really Shady
yeah so and Cathars she's a loser like
alex is like Oh Juliet leaves kara come
here carrots like okay and Garrett's
like sitting like a big dope yeah maybe
the show itself respect you no one has
self-respect except for Alex he has too
much self-respect and he's a [ __ ]
loser Oh [ __ ] he should be acting
like a loser
[ __ ] paulie and then alex is in bed
with another girl oh yeah
what after they legit said so we're back
together yes I thought after they said
that it was going to come out that while
they were on hiatus
sup with someone right which technically
is allowed I would have been I would
have been confused but it looks like
next week he loses his mind without
Juliet as well he should Julian needs to
like go do all around the world like
meet some great guy bring him back to
the key and just like who's like a
photographer a photographer like who
takes that tiki bar house and just live
the life of Riley and it's like or
Juliet should hook up with them yeah
your can meet someone to go to New York
me fed and Juliet Juliet Jen Juliet
because it's like Ben and Juliet we
watched a music video right before we
went on live and it was honestly so
horrifying and honestly I I'm I'm
ashamed to call it a music video because
it was really a student project and
honest this song is bad everything is
bad I'm really losing so much respect
for Madison one by doing the video and
by rationalizing it as that's the
closure that you need in order to have
French but Brandon like you were never
friends with Brandon before so why do
you need to be friends now you guys can
just be exes that's fine and like I'm
sorry this music video isn't like I mean
I guess it's on MTV so it's an MTV music
video that's true actually no they
didn't even play that MTV but like if
you watch the video it's [ __ ] tragic
and the song is even more tragic and
like I just can't believe I think of
Madison is like this classy girl like
old-school glamour looks like just
classic she's like she's a cut above the
rest like there's something about her
that's just like classic - that girl
doesn't do that music video could've
lost me now a word from our sponsors
could listening make you a better parent
a better leader even a better person
could listening to motivating fitness
programs get you fit could listening to
inspire inspire you to start something
new and there's no better place to
listen than audible audible is largest
selection of audiobooks on the planet
and now audible members get more than
ever before each month they get three
titles of their choice one audiobook -
audible originals and fitness programs
that they can get can't get anywhere
else
try it free for 30 days by visiting
audible.com slash toast or by texting
toast to five hundred five hundred and
listen for a change
very nice um you know super great
listener I should do and you are a great
listener the only the only thing I'll
say about the music
is that it's trash and I'll never get
those two minutes of my life back
and for that I'm upset yeah except that
I feel sorry for that other girl that
he's working with because she's actually
to choose it yeah and really pretty
yeah that's dress to the 70s agreed I'll
never forget agree completely vibe 70s
is that everything I think it's almost
noon
Wow I have to go back to bed I can't
believe I'm here once again and like
that I got dressed up and I have to go
dress up again tomorrow because knew I
was coming on the dressed
Nick on the toast Nick on the toes so
we'll put up a card with Nick's photo on
our Instagram and please come up with
some questions because I have no clue
what to say cuz I have to just eat my
words yeah yeah we're about to eat
aha you should see oh she should go on
this walk with Murphy take a [ __ ]
package it up bring it here and we have
to eat it because we're eating [ __ ]
tomorrow you know you're like how did
you even just think of that because
they're eating [ __ ] okay
I'll get my fork you bring the knife and
I'll see you there you grab a spoon
hey so make sure to tune in to Nora's
episode with Nick vile we haven't
decided she would do like a show and
then Nick violin interviewer just like
Ana make a vital super how to do a show
in a Nick dial interview because of his
schedule oh okay great so it's settled
we're doing the full show and an exiled
interview make sure to tune in to the
Millenial morning show tomorrow morning
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube and we're
also available as a podcast where
anywhere podcasts can be found it's been
an absolute pleasure hanging out with
you two this morning
bye bye
you